bonjour bienvenue à râler bull
il n'a pas encore son étoile sur
hollywood boulevard mais c'est tout
comme
julien bocabeille un français de 29 ans
vit à los angeles
depuis cinq ans déjà ses premiers pas
dans la capitale mondiale du cinéma
il n'est pas prêt de les oublier un
sourire que j'ai à chaque fois que je
passe ici c'est évidemment les oscars
tapis rouge célébrités projecteurs
hélicoptères ka mais à toutes les
chaînes de télé sont là mondialement
tous m'ont hélas c'était en février 2009
au dolby theater
julien étaient en compétition cette
année là pour l'oscar du meilleur court
métrage d'animation son film s'appelait
oktapodi l'histoire des amours
contrariées d'un couple de poulpe
[Musique]
ce n'était à l'origine qu'un film de fin
d'études mais la qualité du court
métrage a séduit bien au delà de son
jury d'école le film de julien a été
récompensé dans le monde entier jusqu'à
la consécration
une nomination aux oscars à seulement 23
ans
inespéré quand tu es sur ton anime avec
l'ani montpetit poule b
qui pense même pas jamais là mais on se
serait imaginé se retrouver là pour son
oscar
julien n'a pas remporté l'oscar mais il
est resté à hollywood
comme de nombreuses autres français ils
possèdent cette fameuse french touch
dans recherché aux états unis derrière
les succès mondiaux comme shrek
le chat potté madagascar ou encore kung
fu panda se calque nos deux français
les studios américains raffolent de leur
génie créatif c'est parce qu'elle mange
la dame ils seraient les guns and roses
tous les étudiants français car nos
écoles d'animation sont reconnus comme
les meilleurs au monde avec son histoire
son héritage culturel sa tradition des
beaux-arts et de la bande dessinée
la france est une mine de jeunes talents
et pas seulement de je viens
d'accepter un nouveau travail
depuis peu les américains viennent
réaliser leur film
chez nous les mecs d'or sont attirés par
notre fiscalité est notre régime des
intermittents du spectacle alors à quoi
ressemblent ces frenchy acquis hollywood
déroule le tapis rouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bermuda jolie maison et belles voitures
julien a vite adopté le style
californien après son passage aux oscars
en 2009 il a décroché la lune un job à
los angeles pour le célèbre studio
dreamworks ah bah moi j'étais fou mais
je n'en ai plus l'armée plus la nuit je
regardais j'ai regardé leurs films cinq
fois de suite j étais si tu es fou
j'étais allée sinequa petit étudiant à
paris
tarifs
[Musique]
julien se fait tant de chez dreamworks à
9000 euros net par mois
c'est trois fois plus que ce qu'il
aurait pu gagner en france donc là on va
aller d'environ son métier donner vie
aux personnages du studio il est
animateur 3d
en ce moment il travaille sur le
troisième épisode de kung fu panda à la
fiche dans plus d'un an
il anime les deux héros du film paul
panda et son père adoptif une loi
baptisée gosse dad
aujourd'hui g33 plan donc là j'ai la
chambre de pau par exemple et il est
avec son père voilà et donc ce sont deux
marionnettes qui sont prêtes à animer
chaque partie du corps que je
sélectionne je peux je peux la manipuler
bras le corps les mains tout jusqu'à
l'ongle pouvoir mettre un sourire
le logiciel permet une telle liberté de
création qui a aucune limite à notre
imagination finalement c'est
exceptionnel
l'animateur dispose de plus de 4000
points de contrôle sur le corps des
personnages et les capacités du logiciel
ne faut pas tous les gens qui sont
sceptiques
ça a l'air tellement facile ben oui oui
allez-y après il ya toute une culture de
l'animation de l'image du visuel de
l'acting performance de la caméra du
comment on fait des films qui demande
beaucoup d'études beaucoup de défauts
comme un comédien julien interprète le
rôle de bandas
[Musique]
non
pour trouver le bon geste la bonne
attitude julien prend son temps il va
passer près d'un mois sur cette scène
d'à peine 12 secondes
[Musique]
les conditions de production sont très
confortables et l'ambiance digne des
start up américaines les plus généreux
est donc ce qui est super les grimoires
c'est que tous les jours ils servent le
petit déjeuner le déjeuner et tout est
gratuit
voilà rigoler bérigaud tous les fruits
qu'on veut des autres maires de tout ça
par contre les droits de croissance et
du coup je suis juste allée me rend la
galerie un expresso plus tard étape
ouais montrer - super league
julien retrouve son voisin de bureau
français lui aussi l'animation de lui
allait super bien non pas de problème
parce que je me disais qu'est ce qui
regarde là tu vois ici
christophe ferron a participé à la
création du studio il ya 20 ans il n'est
jamais reparti il est directeur
d'animation une pointure chez dreamworks
bonjour la télé française mind the
french tv
oh voilà j'espère que cette ville
le blagueur est en fait un thannois les
autres sont canadiens ou américains
du haut de ses 20 ans d'expérience le
français supervise le travail
d'animateur venus du monde entier pour
les aider à donner vie aux pingouins les
héros du prochain film du studio leurs
conseils il d'aller voir ailleurs je
vous encourage à aller sur internet donc
être regardés inspiré pas que des choses
comme ça dans l'ambiance
vous voyez des espèces de cette capacité
à puiser dans leur culture
c'est la marque des français nous
apporte quelque chose
un point de vue différent que des
animateurs d'amérique du nord
il ya une tradition en bd et des choses
différentes dans les arts européenne ça
ils sont exposés plus des choses crise y
est ridé canadienne bien ça fait
longtemps qu'elle collabore avec des
frontières pour elle c'est sûr ils ont
plus ils savent très bien raconté les
histoires et orientale vraiment de
départ et non plus un seul coup d'envoi
de ce qu'ils mangent là bas mais non ici
les français peuvent se lâcher c'est
même selon leur demande un peu plus loin
dans les studios
christophe nous présente un inconnu du
grand public
guyomard et hausse et à bien l'un des
créateurs de la plus grande star de
dreamworks
ge serait l'homme votre ado devenu la
figure de proue du studio le succès je
l'installé au sommaire
[Musique]
alors dis merci les gens qu'on fait
chérèque maintenant à brémoy bonhommes
verts qui pète on doit on pensait que ça
marcherait pas tellement iep et aimerait
bien mais c'est pas sûr que ça marche
mais le deuxième a été un succès encore
plus énorme que le premier jamais un
film j'ai au jour d'aujourd'hui encore
shrek 2 le deuxième srec et dans les
trois plus gros films de tous les temps
je dirais c'est incroyable et ses petits
frenchy qui leur rapportent des fortunes
les américains viennent les chercher à
la source
[Musique]
en france 1,9 km de la californie le
xiiie arrondissement de paris
nous sommes à la prestigieuse école des
gobelins depuis 40 ans elle forme les
plus grands professionnels mondiaux de
l'animation
je comprends pas très bien ce que je
vois ça
c'est juste une maquette cette femme
n'est pas professeur à l'école elle
travaille elle aussi pour dreamworks
tous les étudiants m'intéresse c'est
tout ce que je peux vous dire
celle epage est une chasseuse de tête
très discrète
chaque année elle vient aux gobelins
faire son marché
ce qu'elle apprécie ici c'est le côté
polyvalent des étudiants plus scénario à
l'animation en passant par le storyboard
les futurs diplômés savent tout faire le
point fort recherché par les américains
la conception des personnages à la base
on voulait plutôt une jeune femme en
fait
l'adolescente fur et à mesure de
l'histoire a changé et on a fini par
rajeunir la petite fille et au final est
modélisé en plastique ça permet en fait
de voir si les volumes était bon et
agréable à regarder un truc
marion est en troisième et dernière
année depuis sept mois
elle travaille d'arrache-pied avec
d'autres étudiants sur son film de fin
d'études
un court métrage de 3 minutes sept mois
de travail pour trois minutes
le ratio pour une qualité quasi
professionnelle
[Musique]
pour repérer les futurs talents
la recruteuse américain a l'embarras du
choix pas moins de sept films de fin
d'études et la promo 2014 s'annonce
comme un très bon cru
je propose qu'on démarre à moins que des
questions on doit déjà comme des
professionnels c'est le grand jour
aujourd'hui
un jury de professionnels va noter les
étudiants et leurs projets dans la salle
des réalisateurs chevronnés garder
producteur influent bhl est toujours
celle epage du des studios américains
les étudiants le savent elle peut leur
offrir un aller simple pour hollywood
mais rien n'est gagné et quand miss
paige critique leur fille elle ne prend
pas de gants blancs
ça m'a vu refaire un certain de
l'association photo ax très élevé 0,3 en
avril
jamais une chose mais vous doit
s'intéresser à votre reer au moment où
vous sortez d'ici
oui il attendre que vous soyez et nos
pères et l'epha2 que vous allez deux
heures aux demandes de miss paige et
parfois sévères malgré tout elle revient
à paris chaque année les américains
aiment le génie des petits français et
depuis quelques temps ils leur ont même
découvert un nouvel atout
paris xvème arrondissement un ancien
garage réhabilité
[Musique]
ici on fabrique le plus gros carton
mondial de l'animation
waouh trop bien tu vas vraiment sauver
lund légumes
moi moche et méchant
on dirait une superproduction américaine
il s'agit surtout d'un savant bricolage
à la française
exemple avec la voix des millions
mariam et baudoin dos derrière ces
drôles de personnages pas de gros
comédien
ici c'est pierre coffin le coréalisateur
café m'a même les doublages pour le
monde entier
nous les tubes langue de ceux mentionnés
comme toi comment la wind aux pattes à
l'imac halo tapioca qu'aux secousses les
ponots qu'on a marqué tard quand le
volet ben 10
une fois que je transforme le tout en
ligne ont fait ça donne ça un ordinateur
grand public
un banal micros chez lui miner shon mac
guff on serre les coûts au maximum et la
volonté d'économies se retrouve à tous
les étages dans cet espace aux antipodes
du confort des studios américains 600
personnes travaillent sur le prochain
opus aux commandes
à droite le producteur américain chris
meledandri à gauche son associé français
fondateur du studio
si l'américain a investi ici c'est en
partie pour notre fameux régime des
intermittents du spectacle un régime qui
lui permet de faire travailler des
animateurs aux coûts partout dabs fois
que je me rendais cette flexibilité est
quelque chose de très important pour
nous c'est lié à la nature ajoute
business avec les pires qui détenait un
producteur avisé les deux premiers
épisodes de moi moche et méchant ont
rapporté un milliard et demi de dollars
la saga produite à paris fait partie des
films les plus rentables de l'histoire
d'hollywood
alors au parti vers st
on continue d'exploiter le filon
ici les visiteurs sont loin d'imaginer
que les petites gélules jaunes sont en
fait bleu blanc rouge
créativité française et sens des
affaires américain woods a trouvé la
bonne formule le prochain épisode de la
série sortira en salles
quelques mois
[Musique]